good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is scp-1472 class
neutralized formerly safe special
containment procedures the remains of
scp-1472 rest in a small plastic case
within the podium section of its
terrarium
the terrarium is to remain stocked with
salt assets and the offspring of
scp-1472 pending the end of quarantine
period these offspring may be introduced
to the wild if no anomalous behavior is
detected all personnel have been cleared
of quarantine after exposure to scp-1472
effects previous containment procedures
and in May 7th 2008 scp-1472 soundproof
terrarium measuring 0.75 by 2 metres 0.6
meters tall the terrarium includes a
small source of fresh running water and
includes flora common to the Australian
state of Queensland the northeastern
corner of the terrarium has be modified
to allow for communication with scp-1472
slow keishon is referred to as the
podium scp-1472 shades regular content
and is scheduled for interviews three
times daily allowing for a regular
nocturnal sleep schedule if personnel
wish to conduct an unscheduled interview
with a CP 1474 any reason they may do so
am i entering the chamber and vocalizing
their intent to speak with scp-1472 the
podium or respond as it is able it is
not necessary to speak verbally when
communicating with SCP 1471 vocalization
of words helps to convey meaning more
clearly than thinking of abstract
concepts and allows for easier
transcription of communication scp-1472
love understanding the range of human
thought so it is highly recommended the
researchers only use basic concepts and
short statements
scp-1472 areum should be stocked with a
monitor population of mundane salt
assets web building spiders and their
own prey insects to service pray for
scp-1472 best way to distinguish
scp-1472 other salt acids within the
terrarium is to ask it to waive its arms
personnel working with scp-1472
psychological screening on a weekly
basis for a period no less than a year
after exposure description scp-1472 male
fringed jumping spider Portilla fin
Brianna recovered from Queensland
Australia its body measures six point
three millimeters in life SCP 1471 say
piant and capable of telepathic
communication with other sapient beings
at a range of approximately nine metres
although scp-1472 another members of its
species in behavior or physiology the
queensland population of poor TFM briana
has already been observed to be more
intelligent than other spiders in its
ability to solve problems and employ
unique hunting tactics to capture its
prey which primarily consists of other
spiders both of the web spinning
varieties and other members of the salt
acid' a family to which they belong
apart from its ability to communicate
with research personnel scp-1472 splayed
no behavior that was deviant from what
is typical of the Queensland variant of
poor TFM Brianna however due to its
anomalous ability to communicate does
not recommend that any conclusions about
the species be drawn based on the
experiences with
[Music]
communication a-c-p 1470s method of
telepathic broadcast appears to assign
terms on a best-fit basis within the
minds which receive its communications
when scp-1472 parts of its own body
which do not directly correspond to
human anatomy the terms are adjusted
based on its content
for example while leg is a
straightforward translation references
to scp-1472 out were typically perceived
as armed by researchers refer to the
following statement received after an
unsuccessful attempt to introduce
scp-1472 a mate surrounded and I watch
war he wasn't having none of it she
smacked her lips at me and gave me a
good drumming with her arms and legs and
I know it was because of that hideous
red stripe you are that poor amigas it
really makes a fella stand out in ways
he's not supposed to you know those
savages might not notice it much but it
can't fool a proper lady
so anyway I hire Bungie and make a jump
fort before say lobectomy tint to nurse
me pride as his typical of statements
made by a CP 1470 it was perceived in a
way that could almost be spoken by
another human
it was also typical to perceive these
statements in a strong regional dialect
note however that harlot was used as a
derogatory term and does not imply
prostitution a concept alien to Portilla
Finn Brianna lips refer to the cella sir
I wear a spider's fangs are stored arms
refer to the palps bordering the mouth
which are larger in males and used for
display purposes in this case they were
used to make the female aware of
scp-1472 and like of intent to harm her
arse refers to abdomen and the red
strike that was painted there at one
time to distinguish sa P 1470 from other
spiders
tiya Bungie refers to laying down a
safety line of silk before making it
jump off to the surface the spiders were
located on and sailing is a
straightforward description of drifting
down on a loose strand of silk while
airborne
likewise tent refers to scp-1472 used
purely for shelter the red strike was
removed from scp-1472 word and a less
mature female was introduced to the
terrarium the following excerpt was
taken from the subsequent interview Hey
so light your wife a little sailor your
interaction with her seemed to go better
how was she doing she was pretty scared
when she got tossed out here my life's
big predators at least I think she was
she can't talk to me like we can talk no
other movie can what she cares and why
she asked me back to a place and we're
going to stay there until she's ready
ready for what you know can't be a
gentleman if we talk about it so plainly
Emma not the way you guys do anyway I
guess as you say thank you it's not what
I wanted but it'll do you told me you
wanted a mate I told you I wanted a wife
a mate is a friend we're mates right
you're fun to talk to BRR
so I could look in the eyes while I talk
to them we've never found anyone else
that can talk like you do well it's what
separates us from the savages right you
mean your prey species right right
you're different from them because you
can talk like I do I would never eat
something that could talk she can't talk
but I can tell she's like me just needs
Tom DeGray sir that'll be very soon
she'll probably catch more savages than
me - we'll have good children except big
old Holland keeps a distance we've
removed her from the area
note that cohabitation in the same web
between a male and a sexually immature
female is not uncommon in Portilla fin
Brianna the females maturity was reached
within the next two weeks and scp-1472
web after copy living as is normal for
the species the female did not devour or
kill scp-1472 following is excerpts from
the final interview hello I'm here we're
just doing some work and your enclosure
what the podium it's in college billet
don't see you in here I'm outside your
podium the podium doesn't have an
outside Yudof bent come I can't get
outside it do you see me waving my army
oh this is a note from dr. Weston
unintelligible wordless dread would be
the most apt description of what I felt
from scp-1472 podium shortly thereafter
in a manner that suggested it was trying
to avoid a predator for TFM Brianna has
excellent vision although at a very
short range scp-1472 us visually before
but never in such a manner that
suggested it realized we were the beings
speaking with it I will not hurt you we
like talking with you and we want you to
live I never realized you sorry this is
another note from dr. Weston scp-1472
communicate for two hours I remained at
the podium attempting to coax him back
into interaction
I'm sorry I just thought we will like
each other but you just wanted to stay
hidden because I'm kind of the king of
the jungle already at least I thought it
was maybe I should have he's tried hard
not to alarm you what are you I don't
have any answers to that which will make
sense to you but I understand he was
scared I've been scared to buy things
that are as big to me as I am to you is
that hurts to think about I understand
that to the children won't talk to me no
one's lived at doing all right
I guess they isn't important to
something like a youth oh it will be my
job to watch them we were hoping they
could talk like you do even me boys I'm
pretty tired and itchy now I want to
change my kind but I can't sorry for
getting all weird on you earlier I just
wanted you to know that it was nice to
talk to someone while it lasted
note from dr. Westing ttan scp-1472 a
total of three months in foundation
custody before perishing of natural
causes he was not fully mature at the
time of containment so his total
lifespan was estimated to be
approximately four months
okay that about does it for today thank
you all for listening if indeed you
still are go away ah I'm kidding goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tiber ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
as it patreon.com forward slash the
volcan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you